et bien voilà 89 mais je compte la tante
de deux films muets tu te rappelles tu
veux dire oui à temps alors j'ai tourné
un truc qui s'appelait au et les valises
je prends un truc comme ça et puis alors
un autre
gg tourner les lions avec dandy dans des
sketches sketch nivet way avec dandy on
était au moulin roux lui à ce moment là
ensemble ça doit être vert 26-27 mai
s'était tourné au moulin rouge vous
alliez en studio en championnat et téoz
en studio on l'a tourné en deux jours
c'étaient les studios là où il n'y a pas
de lumière entre dans tous les cas non
non on a tourné on a tourné sa ba ou
vous êtes maintenant la télévision la
tournée ça là oû trop de chaumont un
jour il y aura une plate-bande parlant
c'est m us
alors après ses sorties salorges coin
mais c'est parce qu'il y avait des
bruits mettait des bruits dessus
les lions et tout ça c'est très vert 28
ouais quand ils l'ont sorti alors tout
de suite après ces deux ou trois films
et le parlant ces menus comment c'était
du théâtre filmé c'était des chansons
gens c'étaient des opérettes l'opérette
oui mais je vais dire j'étais aux
bouffes à ce moment là et j'étais au
beauf et puis alors c'était l'avènement
du parlant puisque c'est en 30 et il
cherchait
je le premier comics quoi pour tourner
une opérette
alors j'ai été faire un essai chez pathé
et puis moi je l'avais trouvé déplorable
et s'est d'ailleurs retrouvé minable
google impossible enfin pour le manque
ça doit être bon ils m'ont pris et c'est
quand j'ai débuté dans une opérette qui
s'appelait chacun sa chance tes jouets
des grandes revues d'ailleurs et au
mistinguett et damien et un tas de gens
avaient c'est à dire qu'elle est à la
fois l'effet mon tour de chant j'ai fait
au moulin rouge
et c'est damien qui passait en vedette
dans le programme et comment ça se
passait à cette époque on se faisait
entendre il y avait entre la sono comme
ils disent maintenant à brasilia pour
tuer les pigeons il y avait un drôle
darkest y avait au moins trente
musiciens elle est passée par dessus
alors qu'ils venaient chanter au procès
n'y sommes pour que ça passe pour que
les gradués aux attentes
c'est un autre métier mot chapeau
comment ils font maintenant tu as
beaucoup chanté ensemble on a des
disques de ça on allait on a des
souvenirs de ça on en entend de temps en
temps une chanson qu'on entendit a pas
tellement longtemps à la radio à salou
est un vieux disque qu'ils ont dit adieu
et quand il se prend le contrôle promène
au bord de l'eau est rare et où est une
chanson que je chantais dans le film
d'olivier la belle équipe
puis alors attendre à cette époque là
alors il n'y avait pas de playback
j'ai enregistré directement nés dont je
me la suis tapé au moins 6 cette fois
non
aux très beaux lots
et alors ça nous amène au cinéma parlant
et aux grands films qu'elle est le
premier grand film que côté fait qui
était fait vraiment envie de démarrer
il va écoute je vais dire c'est un
c'était un film charmant
d'après une pièce d'achat d'achard qui
s'appelait la belle marinière
j'ai tourné avec madeleine renaud que
j'adore entre parenthèses alors malade
ans laurie est pire blancheur et ça
s'appelait la belle marinière ici
lachmann qui avait mis en scène
c'était le premier importance oui avec
également un joli film mais alors le
film le relevant le premier film alors
où j'ai démarré avec la bande à 1,34 du
vivier de duvivier du vivier a tourné
six ou sept fois
oui bah le premier film que les fêtes du
village abdallah après il m'a fait une
vacherie me fais tourner ponce pilate
non golgoth ah oui d'ailleurs la
cuillère oui avec feuillard je l'appelle
toujours madame pause les employeurs
disent bonjour madame pons et il ya eu
d'ailleurs aussi jettent aussi bien une
critique fine minable de gens sont
formidables
je me suis jamais tant marais à ce
moment là j'étais au cannet au canard
enchaîné et il avait écrit qu'en taille
à main il a plutôt l'air de décembre de
la courtille audi golgotha mais il s'en
lavent l'époque c'est guérineau cet
amuse maintenant mais l'époque bombe ou
supra est trop gros bol je suis mal
tellement mal oui l'a d'ailleurs pas mal
écrit pourquoi je fais pépé le moko avec
lui puis d'autres où l'on appelle plus
dans tout ça au fond avant guerre
c'était ses terrines des grands metteurs
en scène à tourner avec carnet dit
vivier là que les tornades du vivier
renoir carnet
les millions si je fais plusieurs films
avec ces gars là oui chacun soient
finalement moins dans l'ensemble presque
tous les presque tous les films que j'ai
fait et j'ai fait avec très peu de
metteur en scène parce que j'ai tourné
qu'à tous un film avec chaque metteur en
scène des fois plus d'ailleurs ça veut
dire que tu es fidèles ou ça veut dire
quoi
peut-être oui peut-être oui je suis
fidèle je suis fidèle puis j'aime avoir
mes habitudes mais tu sais je suis pas
je pense comme ça je suis à mon aise
avec et comme je connais aussi bien pour
les équipes d'ailleurs pour les équipes
d'opérateurs pour l'équipe pour le son
j'aime pas me retrouver au tc en pays
étranger les me retrouvais mes vieilles
habitudes et je suis un vieux schnock
maintenant et puis j'ai eu la guerre
l'occupation et la carrière américaine
le dernier film les tournées ces
rendements de 39 à 47
j'ai eu un taux et puis évidemment les
faits deux films en amérique pour conter
cet ouvrage qui obligeait défaire pour
bouffer comme l'a dit parce que je
m'étais bas et non pas pour plaisir
d'aller en amérique je le dis tout était
franchement mais c'est parce que j'avais
l'autre allant de foot l'attenté donc je
voulais pas venir travailler à paris
sitap leurs jupes article j'ai eu
l'occasion de partir je suis parti
et puis et puis après il s'était
accroché mais enfin c'est toujours
difficile de répondre en premier
ça a été dur tout c'est vrai ça c'est ce
que j'appelle alors ma période noire
quand le contrat pour le voir flotter
sur la marmite
c'était pour briand pas forcément tu
sais je suis parti j'avais 37 ans alors
je suis parti j'étais en plein boom caps
que je vais tourner tous les bons films
comme les collègues j'ai tourné à piles
aiea est allée puis soit venu j'avais
chou blanc alors tu sais ce que c'est et
surtout quand ça change et ça change et
le personnage alors j'ai tourné si je
tournais un très bon film avec les mots
qui s'appelait rue de la décrire un très
bon film mais c'était pas reparti pour
autant et les gens croient que c'est
reparti après le grisbi se pressent par
tient non après ce but non pierre où
c'est bien reparti et à partir des
grandes familles là j'en ai fait toute
une série combien marché enfin il pas
teulière en particulier bâtonnière avec
de la nouère j'ai fait les maigret
danois et le baker et de la noire et
puis alors j'ai fait
avancis en un gars très bien marché
c'est la traversée de paris
un mauvais mois pour vendre et oui c'est
un grossier et puis alors j'en ai fait
avec gilles avec grange est alors des
bons si j'ai fait
le cave se rebiffe le fils cardinaux
appelés salle sans à la tête non
seulement beaucoup d'ailleurs alfie
scardino son fils jean à la tête gabas
et l époque on sait qu'il met des doutes
la colère nourrissent et c'était
collègues qu'ils y donc temps lyse'k si
j'avais pris un set de colère je
tournais pas tu parles bien plus
fatigant alors je tiens produits d'où un
tournée scènes de colère à lui tout mais
qu'ils avaient même dit que c'était dans
ses contrats weir belle connerie entre
nous remarque t il
ils ont de l'imagination afat avait
quand même beaucoup de scènes de colère
dans tout film avant vieux gm doit y
aller les scènes de colère parce que
c'est les gars qui m'a claqué des scènes
de colère ce tel sujet kim tillie qui
voulait ça moi personnellement je tiens
pas du tout
j'aime mieux tourner un petit risque
pénal tu sais moi j'en fais plus je suis
content moi mettez en scène alors ça n'a
jamais dit de le faire
il ya un moment où j'aurais aimé tu sais
si j'avais mis en scène
d'abord il aurait fallu une bonne
histoire et je leur ai fait pour les
acteurs parce que moi j'adore les
acteurs
j'adore c'est chouette des actes des
acteurs sur le titre à lui tout quand
même la première qu'on raconte cambourin
des séries qui traduit
non